[Music]
hey you guys here i am back again with
another book review i don't know what
the deal is with my voice i keep like it
keeps the words like keep dropping out i
don't have a cold or anything like that
i don't know what's the matter with it
so i apologize for hopefully it'll
not sound like this from now on like for
the rest of my life or whatever so
anyway book review time
my tombs of terror show and this is a
book that i had been talking about doing
i think i talked about this even way
back in january that i was really
looking forward to rereading this book
and doing a review on it because i read
it back probably like the same year that
it came out
which was 2009 and i really really dug
it and i was like yeah okay i'm just
gonna i think the the first time i read
it i think i checked it out of the
library
so i actually went and like bought a
copy so i could redo it for the show and
i've talked about it multiple times on
the show and recommended it although i
will say just spoiler alert that
this is not a book i would recommend to
anybody it's one that i'd have to kind
of know
what your
literary proclivities and tastes were uh
before i would think that uh that you
would like it because one
it's a chunker uh it's almost 800 pages
and it's very very dense and it's very
very literary so if that sounds like
something that's gonna make you go
boring then i would not recommend it but
i [ __ ] loved this book i just got so
and the first time i read it
and i think i liked it even better the
second time uh i just got so swept up in
it in its world you know what i mean
it's just a great great [ __ ] book uh
i kind of feel like guillermo del toro
for a long time was talked about doing a
movie version of this
but far as i know it's still in
development so and it has been like way
back since the [ __ ] novel came out
back in 2009 so
i mean i really really hope that uh
because guillermo del toro would make a
[ __ ] epic movie of this um and i'd
really like to see it although maybe a
series would actually work out better
but maybe not
but i don't know if it's ever gonna
happen i hope it does but i don't know
man this is like i said i've brought
this up on many occasions this is drewed
by dan simmons
now if you guys remember
a while back i had reviewed because i've
read several dan simmons uh novels i
read summer of night i read the terror i
read like a bunch of other ones and uh
he's really good at doing kind of
different like he does horror novels he
does like historical fiction this is
kind of mostly historical fiction but
has a lot of
horror elements in it but remember like
a while back when i reviewed the fifth
heart
which i found a hardback of that in like
a used bookstore and it seemed to be
because i heard already read drude at
that point and i was kind of like it
sounded like it was along the same lines
because it was henry james who was you
know a real guy obviously uh working
teaming up with sherlock holmes like to
solve a mystery and i didn't love that
one as much i just i think it was
because
maybe it was more based around sherlock
holmes lore and it was more based around
a mystery and the mystery to me wasn't
all that compelling um so it didn't
really have like a lot of horror
elements whereas drude is much more like
i said i don't think i'd call it a
horror novel outright
but it has a lot more horror elements
than the fifth hard hat i mean a lot
more um there's a lot of like really
creepy [ __ ] going on in this whether
it's real or not um i don't want to
spoil too much about it because i think
the best thing about this book is just
letting yourself get entirely involved
in
this world and in this situation and
like i said this is you know it's real
characters it's real people that
actually did live
but it's sort of
fictionalized to an extent although i
will say just from
you know just kind of like a peremptory
reading of the biographies of both the
characters involved it really does seem
like dan simmons took great great pains
to get all of the biographical details
of all of this stuff right so
i would say probably like 95 of the
stuff that happens in this book like
actually did happen like to these people
but then the rest of it is like kind of
fanciful but like i said you don't
really know if like what's entirely real
and what's not
uh so basically the story of this book
it's told from the point of view of
wilkie collins
who was a very very popular famous
novelist uh back in the late 19th
century
um i haven't read a [ __ ] ton of his
stuff but i did read the woman in white
which was excellent and i also read the
moonstone which i actually really loved
um he's actually
uh he may have come up with uh in the
moonstone he actually did kind of come
up with what they think might be the
first english detective novel so he is
actually uh you know quite well you know
in known in that regard but he's
primarily known i think at least
nowadays as being a collaborator
a frequent collaborator and friend of
charles dickens who obviously is way way
more famous
than wilkie collins which i said it's
kind of a shame because
honestly i've read i haven't read all of
dickens stuff but obviously i've read a
christmas carol i read great
expectations i read a tale of two cities
i read like a bunch of uh stuff of his
and
i have to say that
out of all the stuff i've read of both
dickens and wilkie collins i'm gonna say
i like wilkie collins stuff a little bit
better i do kind of feel like dickens
had a tendency to sort of like i don't
know there's just something about his
stuff that never really like grabbed me
whereas wilkie collins he wrote more of
like sensationalistic
um you know maybe not by today's
standards obviously but
he wrote kind of more horror mystery
uh type stuff and i don't know that just
like appealed to me more like i said i
think the moonstone was is a great
[ __ ] uh book like a detective book
and uh you know it's the first one like
i said in english language and uh so
so what they kind of used so this book
kind of uses
uh that
to
sort of explore
because it's it's all from wilkie
collins point of view
and the the conceit of this is that
he's writing this massive
uh memoir
uh about charles dickens and about drude
and about all these other things that
happened like the last five years of
charles dickenson's life
and he's writing that like on his
deathbed essentially or like you know
he's dying because he's an ill health so
he's been working on it for a few years
and he's made a stipulation in his will
that
this is uh that this memoir is not to be
published until like i think he says
like 125 years after he's dead he's
actually addressing us the reader of the
future um and he's like you know i want
to set the record straight about all
this stuff that happened like the last
five years of charles dickinson's life
and all this like weird [ __ ] about drude
now uh one thing and like i said i don't
think this is a spoiler alert but
i will say that wilkie collins
is kind of like this is kind of like um
you know amadeus the movie uh you know
which was based on the play where it
kind of like posits that mozart and uh
salieri
who were kind of friends and
collaborators in real life
but they sort of like dramatized it so
it's like salieri like hated mozart's
guts because he was way better
he was a way better composer than him
and he was always like jealous and
overshadowed and almost that he like
caused his death or sort of like
murdered him
this is kind of along the same lines
from what i can tell from real life i
don't know like i said i'm not really
really familiar with their biographies
uh you know kind of surface level stuff
uh but they were
friends for a very long time they
collaborated on
not only on lots of plays and things
like that but they also collaborated on
lots of like christmas stories they had
um a magazine like all the year round i
think they had actually more than one i
think they had one called household
words but uh you know they so they
edited each other's work and
things of that nature and they were also
like acted in some of their own plays
and all that other kind of stuff and
we're just constantly like reading stuff
back and forth to each other like
staying you know wilkie collins stayed
at his house all the time and stuff like
that now there are some whiffs i think
that they actually like kind of bitchily
criticized each other's [ __ ] um because
i think there were some things uh with
wilkie collins like in some of his
letters like kind of
uh denigrating like some of charles
dickens stuff and then like charles
dickens maybe denigrating the moonstone
like when that came out like the wilkie
collins novel so there is some kind of
like hint that there maybe was some
rivalry i don't know if it's as
pronounced as it in the book but like i
said this is like a mozart salieri
situation where we're maybe taking
something of like some little germ
of wilkie collins being a little
resentful that charles dickens was so
much more famous than him uh even though
he you know he was actually quite
popular at the time but like he lived
long enough after charles dickens died
like to see uh his novels kind of like
falling out of favor and charles dickens
fame just growing and growing so you
could say you could just take that
little germ of resentment and you could
like you know make this big story out of
it
so what we have
and like i said wilkie collins in this
this is all from his point of view and
his memoir
and he is
not only an unreliable narrator uh which
will be clear when you read this like i
said i don't think that's really a
spoiler alert he's also very very
unlikable and it's like everything that
he talks about in this i mean he's just
like a [ __ ] person it's just you know
what i mean he's just like a garbage
fire of a person but
he's still like he still want to like
read the [ __ ] from his point of view
because it's just like a fascinating
story but he's just like such a [ __ ] he
is just like always denigrating like
charles dickens and stuff like in this
really like throwing shade sort of way
and it's like you know and and my copy
and then my like book blah blah blah
like sold so many more copies than
charles so he's always kind of like
blowing up his own ego
uh at the expense of even though they're
like nice to each other's faces so it's
like so it's almost kind of like this
constant [ __ ] fest but it's like it's
he's unlikable but it's like really
entertaining like in an entertaining
kind of way he's also really unlikable
in the sense that one he's constantly
like complaining how much pain he's in
um he had gout
even though some have speculated that
maybe it was syphilis
that he just said it was gout because it
wasn't like polite
to say that he had like an std but i
don't really know but uh but he just
keeps saying it's gout so as the book
goes on he becomes more and more
addicted to
uh laudanum opium morphine uh which
actually did happen in real life um you
know so so that's pretty historically
accurate and he was just at one point
and i think i mentioned this on one of
our shows but you know when they when
they used to do laudanum it was kind of
like you put like a few drops of opium
into one into like red wine or something
and it's like that you'd put like two or
three drops in there whereas in this
book i'm not sure about real life but
wilkie collins was straight up chugging
like two or three glasses of the [ __ ] a
day just because he was saying he was in
so much pain all the time and then as he
got older the more pain and the more uh
you know laudanum the more opium he had
to take and then his doctor started
prescribing morphine because he couldn't
really work anymore and then his vision
started to go which
factors into this story as well so uh
and like i said he's also and this is
also historically accurate he's also uh
really really anti-marriage um he
doesn't really like he likes to have sex
with women but he thinks that marrying
them is like a trap and that women are
all trying to like entrap uh dudes and
like get all their money and then just
like [ __ ] at them forever and nag at
them forever so he's that kind of dude
and uh so what he did throughout his
life
was that he had
a couple of mistresses one of him was
named caroline and she uh her and her
daughter uh you know buy another
marriage or whatever she was a widow i
think um but she lived in his house and
he said on his taxes that that was his
housekeeper even though they were
clearly [ __ ] um and he also had
another mistress named martha and he had
like two or three kids with her i think
but he would never
marry them so like i said so so don't go
into this like thinking you're gonna
like this dude because he's a horrible
horrible person but in that way but he's
still like a really entertaining
narrator and like i said as the book
goes on
and he starts talking about
uh you know his opium addiction and
stuff because he's like very he's really
into the opium he's basically like well
i need it because i'm in constant pain
all the time and i just have to like
chug more and more and i think it's this
amazing medicine so you're not real sure
i mean even pretty early on in the story
um you're pretty sure that this opium is
addling his brain somewhat because he
just he says like very matter-of-factly
and i don't even think this is that far
into the book
that
there is a woman
with green skin and like fangs and she
lives in his house like in his servant
staircase and he's the only one that can
see her so
he seems to know oh and he also has
there's this other apparition that he
calls the other wilkie and it's
essentially like his doppelganger so
he's clearly not super at his right mind
you know what i'm saying like even blake
from the job
so basically what happens at the
beginning of the book
is that charles dickens uh who also has
a mistress yeah charles dickens had a
wife named what was her name catherine
and i think they had like 10 kids or
some [ __ ] like that and he got sick of
her so he just like chucked her out and
then he started uh buffing this uh this
actress named ellen turnen i think is
her name
uh but he didn't want anybody to know
about it so he had like ellen turning
and her mom are like he has him set up
uh you know in this cottage somewhere
that he's rented under an assumed name
so they were all like doing that kind of
like shady [ __ ]
so uh so yeah so he's on this train
with his mistress and his mistress's mom
one day
and i think in what is really a real
historical thing that happened uh the
train derails uh on its way to
staplehurst and basically most of the
first class carriage he was in one of
the first class carriages like with his
mistress and the mom but they were the
only ones in there all of the first
class carriages but that one went off
like a trellis and like fell into like
this big ravine and pretty much [ __ ]
everybody up but like killed a bunch of
people
um charles dickens i think they're i
don't know how accurate this is to like
the actual incident but their car was
like kind of hanging off the edge but it
didn't fall and they were essentially
unhurt although charles dickens um
really had a problem like with anxiety
like uh being on trains pretty much from
then on out which like i said not
surprising
so this happens uh as i said he's unhurt
and he gets out of the car
out of the train car and he goes down to
the bottom of the ravine and he's trying
to help like the other people that were
hurt in the train accident
now while he's doing this he notices
this really really weird dude like this
guy is
like super super pale
and he's kind of almost bald and he's
wearing this really like out of style
like an opera cape and a weird like out
of style top hat
and he's really really
um he like he doesn't have a nose kind
of like he his nose looks like a
skeleton nose almost like someone cut
his nose off he doesn't have any eyelids
and he has these like really sharp
little teeth like he's filed his teeth
down to points
and this guy like he sees him like kind
of gliding around among the bodies and
stuff and then the guy comes up to him
and he knows who he is and he has this
really creepy like hiss voice and
everything and then uh charles dickens
like sees the guy like going over to
people that are hurt in the accident and
then when he goes over there uh to check
on the people he sees that they're dead
so it's almost so he gets the impression
he tells wilkie collins later that he's
like it's almost like he was like
sucking out their souls or he was
helping them to die like he was the grim
reaper or something like that and he was
just this really really creepy looking
guy and so
he's telling all this to his friend
wilkie collins he's like you know i had
this amazing thing happened like you
know after this horrible train accident
and i saw this really crazy dude and i
can't stop thinking about him
so wilkie collins at first is just kind
of like um okay it's like he's not
really super buying it
but then charles dickens like i said or
at least he says to wilkie collins he's
like i'm really like i'm obsessed with
this dude i gotta find out what the [ __ ]
he was up to um i just can't stop
thinking about it so he basically
enlists wilkie
to
go down to this
what they uh they end up like later in
the book like calling it undertown
essentially what this is is almost kind
of like an underground city like
underneath london now i know that there
really is [ __ ] like that because you
know there's sewers and
catacombs and stuff like that but what
this book posits
is that drude uh this creepy dude that
uh dickens saw at the train wreck
is
uh lives in this kind of underground
slump like it's an underground city
essentially and it's all the people you
know is and obviously this is the
victorian era so the london of the time
uh you know had some really horrible
horrible poverty and horrible slums and
everything like that so this is positing
that even people that were too poor for
that uh had to go underground and like
live in the sewers essentially um and
there's like hints that there's maybe
cannibals and all this other stuff going
on down there
and uh dickens is like fascinated with
it so he takes wilkie collins one night
he the two of them they go he hires this
um
this kind of like big burly like
detective dude to kind of go down there
for det for protection and they're gonna
go into this kind of underground world
like looking for druid i forgot to
mention too that in real life uh charles
dickens's
final unfinished novel uh they actually
back in the day back in the victorian
era they actually used to serialize a
lot of novels so like the magazine would
come out and it would have like one
installment and then there'd be like you
know six or twelve or whatever and then
like later on they would have it bound
as a book and you know and what have you
so uh so charles dickens had had worked
on this mystery called the mystery of
edwin drude
and it was never finished
i believe only six installments of it
were published and then he died
and um so people have tried so so it's
kind of like i think that was kind of
where the jumping off place for this
novel was
was that no one really knows what the
solution of the mystery was because
charles dickens one didn't finish the
book and also didn't leave any notes as
to how the book was going to finish and
it's thought there actually were like
later like after he died there were some
writers that tried to solve it like from
the clues that had been there and like
tried to write their own endings of it
and one of these it is suspected was
actually written by wilkie collins and
charles and one of charles dickens's
sons but they're not really sure um
wilkie collins said that no it wasn't
him but that was kind of like the
speculation at the time but yeah so
they're they're kind of so he's kind of
like using as uh jumping off plays for
this novel the fact that charles dickens
didn't finish this novel and nobody knew
the solution of the mystery now as the
story goes on it kind of like goes like
i said it's set over a five-year period
so it's almost kind of like it gets to a
point where every year on the
anniversary of the train wreck dickens
seems to like disappear for a little
while almost like he's going underground
and likes meeting with drude because
there's also this whole thing where
where charles dickens is um actually
an expert at mesmerism
or you know it's kind of like hypnotism
but you can like get people to do [ __ ]
for you and
what wilkie
thinks is going on is that charles
dickens is going down into undertown
like down into the sewers into these
crypts and everything like that and he's
like learning
better mesmerism techniques from drude
because later charles dickens comes up
and tells him that drew like he kind of
tells him drew's life story like he's
this he's like half egyptian and he's
really into
um mesmerism and it's he has this whole
cult
of people
that he almost kind of like can control
through you know mind control mesmerism
also it's implied that he might not be
alive at least in the way that
we understand it because it seems like
the reason that he doesn't have a nose
and eyelids and stuff like that is that
when he first got to england he
was attacked by a bunch of thugs and
they cut off his eyelids and stuff like
that but and they thought he was dead
but then he ended up living or he
resurrected himself like using his
mesmerism powers so
so there's this whole implication
that this druid person is actually not
entirely like a real
it's not a person in the sense like he
said he's not like a vampire or anything
like that but he's almost like a
resurrected uh dude like he resurrected
himself through kind of like ancient
egyptian magic so there's a lot of like
egyptian
kind of thing which kind of reminded me
of young sherlock holmes a little bit um
you know with the whole like underground
egyptian cult
so as it goes on like wilkie and charles
dickens's uh relationship over this
five-year period
begins to sort of sour like at times
because wilkie
he's kind of becoming obsessed with
drude as well like at first he didn't
really believe that charles dickens had
seen this guy but as time goes on other
people get involved like there's also
another detective who's basically
convinced and he says to wilkie he's
like look you really need to spy on
charles dickens for me i think he's in
danger because he's going and meeting
with druid we think because we're having
him followed and drood is really
dangerous because he lives in this
underground city and he has like
hundreds and thousands of
followers that he basically mind
controls into doing whatever he wants
and he has probably been responsible for
at least like 300 something murders
around london so as other people kind of
become involved in this wilkie becomes
convinced that
drewd is actually a real person is
actually a real danger so he's kind of
like trying to
sort of investigate
what the hell charles dickens wants with
drude and then he kind of starts to get
haunted by him as well like he starts
having you know uh visions of him um and
various things so and like i said in his
drug addiction is getting worse as well
and and it starts to go to a point where
he's gotten to such a point where he's
so paranoid that he thinks that he might
have to actually kill charles dickens
and he sort of like makes the plan to do
it so like i said very much like a
mozart salieri type of situation
but with way way way more opium
and like mesmerism and like weird
egyptian [ __ ] uh there's also one point
too where wilkie becomes convinced that
drude has put a like a magical scarab or
something like that like into his brain
which is like controlling his thoughts
so there's that whole situation too but
yeah so like i said i hesitate to
just recommend this across the board
because this is very much i mean whether
you like this book or not is very much
gonna depend upon i mean i don't think
that
you don't need to have read
um any of charles dickinson stuff uh or
any of wilkie collins's stuff but
it would help and like if you're real
into that like victorian era literature
if you're into that time period then it
really does uh lend a richness to the
story because like i said there's so
much
biographical detail in here there's so
much stuff about
charles dickens's work and wilkie
collinson's work it's because at some
points like during this five-year period
um charles dickens is doing like uh
reading tours of like the england and
like the united states and there's a lot
of that in there wilkie collins is
working on the moonstone you know the
novel and uh so there so there's a lot
of that stuff in there but
over and and like i said there's a lot
of stuff too about the sort of rivalry
between the two of them the friendship
between the two of them which starts to
fracture wilkie's possibly slipping
sanity and his ever increasing drug use
and you're not really sure entirely like
who's telling the truth about this druid
character where he actually lives where
he comes from
you know is he really this criminal
mastermind or is he just misunderstood
you know so it kind of goes back and
forth
uh with some of the characters being
like oh he's he's not real or he's just
like an urban legend essentially or he
is really real and he's really dangerous
and so there's all this kind of like
everybody's like spying on each other
and like all this kind of stuff so it's
just and like i said because
of wilkie collins in particular because
this is from his point of view and
because he's an opium addict there's a
lot of
horror elements in the sense that not
only the stuff about drude which is
creepy and all the stuff about kind of
like the underground city and like these
crazy like egyptian temples like that
are underneath this the ground um so
there's all that kind of stuff but
there's also like the crazy [ __ ] that he
sees that he pretty much knows it
doesn't seem clear from how he talks
that he
he seems to know that there are
hallucinations to a degree like the the
green-skinned woman and the other wilkie
he seems to know that they're
hallucinations because he really he does
seem to say in the text that nobody sees
them but him
but
on the other hand he talks about them
as though they're real and then there's
also a couple of
points in the novel where it seems like
somebody else sees them
so
but but like i said as it goes on
because of his addiction and because of
his of something that happens later that
i'm not gonna spoil you're not entirely
sure how reliable he is as a narrator
like he could just be
like the stuff that he's saying could
be um not exactly what's happening and
it's just and everything is sort of
filtered through his perception so
you're not entirely sure how much of the
[ __ ] that happened like happened the way
that he described it happening
so there's that too so like i said um i
loved this book and i was like so
excited to like reread it again because
i think i read it yeah i got out of the
library like back in 2009 it came out
very early in 2009 like in february and
i think i got when my library got it a
couple months later and i read it after
that and i just like couldn't put it
down i was just like i was totally
immersed uh in this world i mean it's
just so vividly drawn and i think one of
the things that i didn't like about the
fifth heart
was um and i think i mentioned this in
my review of it was that i thought it
went on like for pages and pages uh too
long of like describing uh you know what
the world's fair looked like and all
this other kind of stuff where i thought
that that wasn't really necessary this
one has a lot of extraneous detail too
but i feel like it's more
uh it's paced better it's spaced out
better and it really does it really is
in the surf the service of like
immersing you in this victorian era and
this just creepy like these creepy like
[ __ ] smeared streets and fog and rain
and these underground crypts and there's
all that kind of stuff so i guess
because it had more of a horror element
to it whereas the fifth heart was just
kind of more like a pretty standard
mystery um so i think this one is a lot
more
just had a lot more visceral impact for
me just because it had all of that great
like creepy very gothic victorian
imagery like i was you know everything
was church yards and just creepy old
crumbling
crypts and uh you know underground uh
you know going through the sewers in a
boat and like you know cannibal kids and
[ __ ] like that uh you know and like i
said in this whole and this really
really creepy
uh figure of drude who you're not
entirely sure like what this guy is or
what he's capable of because he just
keeps to turning up like at all these
places and just the description of him
like sounds so unsettling and his
presence just kind of like looms over
the whole thing so i think that's like
really really well done
but as i said even though this is more
it's not a straight-up horror novel i
would call it historical fiction
with horror elements but i would really
really recommend it if you i mean if you
liked the terror because that was kind
of a similar thing where it was
historical fiction but then it also had
like a horror supernatural element this
is kind of like along those same lines i
think that i like this one better than
the terror um i guess because i'm more
of a
literary
person like and i had actually read some
of wilkie collins's stuff and i actually
had read some of charles dickenson's
stuff so
so i think that appealed to me more
because i knew a lot more about that
world and what was in victorian era
fiction and stuff um if you're not into
that kind of stuff then you might just
think this is like boring as [ __ ] uh
which you know i get that that's a
legitimate complaint so i'm so i'm not
going to say go into this like thinking
it's going to be like
you know wham bang this big like horror
whatever it's more like a creepy
unsettling
mystery that goes off in all these kind
of vast tendrils but like i said this
one
as opposed to the fifth heart maybe this
is just my perception of it but the
fifth heart seemed to go off on a lot of
tangents that didn't really seem to
serve the central narrative
whereas
this one seems a lot more focused in
that yes while it goes off on different
things and they talk about you know
stuff that was in real life going on at
that time like i said like charles
dickens's um you know tour like his
reading tour of the united states and it
kind of talks about that talks about
wilkie collins and talks about him
working on the moonstone and how they
got ideas and you know reading to each
other but
it but it always comes back to the
central druid mystery um you know who
that guy is where is charles dickens
going like is he really like in service
to this guy now is this guy like
like mesmerizing like taking him over
and like making him do his bidding he
and like wilkie collins even thinks for
a time that maybe charles dickens killed
somebody um you know and like covered it
up for whatever reason so it's just so
there's all this kind of so there's the
mystery in this is like way more potent
i think uh than the one that was in
fifth hearts which i think which is why
i liked this one so much more just the
atmosphere of this one is just fantastic
and i'm really really glad that i reread
it
the second time but yeah if that sounds
like something you would like like i
said it's a commitment uh it's very very
very long
um i actually i'm recording this review
like literally like an hour or two
before i have to like put it up because
um i was just like i i spent like all
day reading because it i don't think it
took me that long to read the first time
but i was just kind of like i guess
because i was busy and i just kept you
know having to come back to it and so it
took me like way longer than it normally
would like to read it but yeah it's
super long um but if that sounds like
something you would like and if you like
dan simmons other stuff particularly his
historical fiction um i think this is uh
this is like my favorite historical
fiction of his that i read i think of i
can't remember
i've read like some a bunch of his other
ones that i think were uh really good
too like carrying comfort is really good
and all his other kind of stuff too but
yeah definitely check out drewd like i
said hopefully hopefully one day uh
guillermo del toro
del toro if i could say his [ __ ] name
um we'll
get to make the movie out of it because
i just think that would be
uh fantastic but it seems like such a
long time that i feel like it's probably
not gonna happen now but i'm still kind
of hoping
maybe someday but uh yeah so definitely
check out drewd if it sounds like it's
your cup of tea or your glass of opium
as the case may be and i will see you
guys on the next tomes of terror bye